un acuerdo crucial para paliar la crisis
alimentaria este viernes Rusia y Ucrania
bajo la mediación de Turquía y Naciones
Unidas llegaron a un acuerdo para dar
salida a las más de 22 millones de
toneladas de grano que llevan meses
atrapados en los puertos ucranianos
Este es un acuerdo para el mundo traerá
alivio a los países en desarrollo al
borde del colapso y a las personas más
vulnerables al borde de la hambruna y
ayudará a estabilizar los precios
mundiales de los alimentos que ya
estaban en niveles récord incluso antes
de la guerra una verdadera pesadilla
para los países en desarrollo Aunque la
implementación de lo pactado este
viernes en Estambul no será inmediata
habla de cuestiones importantes como la
apertura de un corredor seguro en el mar
Negro para trasladar los granos que
luego saldrán por el Estrecho del
bósforo hacia los mercados globales el
monitoreo de los mismos buques por parte
de un centro de coordinación conjunta
que será el organismo que actuará en
caso de incidente Por otra parte
funcionarios rusos ucranianos y de la
ONU inspeccionarán los barcos antes de
su llegada a Ucrania y ambas naciones se
comprometen a no atacar Los buques algo
imprescindible para Ucrania
en primer lugar los rusos están
obligados a garantizar que no atacarán
habrá un corredor por el que los barcos
navegarán esto quedará fijado en nuestro
acuerdo con la ONU y el acuerdo de Rusia
con la ONU que ningún barco avión ruso
se acercará a este corredor
para Rusia por su parte este acuerdo es
un paso para garantizar la seguridad
alimentaria
de los productos agrícolas rusos y
ucranianos en los mercados mundiales
garantizar su exportación ininterrumpida
responde a las tareas urgentes de
mantener la seguridad alimentaria
especialmente para los países en
desarrollo y menos desarrollados todo
ello debería contribuir a la consecución
de los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible incluida la erradicación del
hambre
Este es el primer gran acuerdo entre
ambos países a las puertas de cumplirse
cinco meses de guerra en suelo ucraniano